morning everyone it is seven o'clock you
are very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show this Thursday morning
here on Sky News Liz trust makes her
debut on the global stage with a
stinging message to Vladimir Putin
prisoner swamps in Ukraine GPS hit back
at the government's new plan for
patience and could we see the biggest
interest rate rise in more than 30 years
all out to come this morning plus we'll
look at the challenges facing the NHS
with workers on the front line it's
Thursday the 22nd of September
catastrophic failure Liz trust tells the
UN President Putin's nuclear threats
won't work
we will not rest until Ukraine prevails
on the way home five British men who
were detained by russian-backed
separatists while fighting in Ukraine
have been released
and in Ukraine a total of more than 280
detainees are exchanged in the biggest
prisoner swap since the War Began
the government sets out new plans to
improve access to the NHS for GPS so it
will have minimal impact
and the biggest blow to the housing
market in more than 30 years is the Bank
of England mulled that interest rate
rise which will be a real blow
here in Huddersfield a merger
investigation is underway after a 15
year old boy was stabbed to death
outside a school
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world Ukrainian ambassador to
the UK will be here to give his thoughts
on the kremlin's latest escalation in
Ukraine and
eat it
the New Evidence which shows even babies
in the womb don't want to eat their
greens
[Music]
hi everyone very good morning to you it
is her first speech on the world stage
as prime minister Liz truss as accused
of Vladimir Putin of saber rattling
telling the United Nations that the
Russian president is desperately trying
to justify a catastrophic failure in
Ukraine yesterday the Russian president
raised the stakes in the conflict
threatening the use of nuclear weapons
where leaders gathered in New York were
United in their condemnation here's Mark
Stone
I have great pleasure prime minister for
less than three weeks and already taking
to the podium on the world stage on a
day when Russia threatened nuclear war a
moment for Liz trust to make her mark
That's about words but delivery too
no one is threatening Russia
being used to kill and maim people
rape is being used as an instrument of
War families are being torn apart and
this morning we have seen Putin trying
to justify his catastrophic failures
her late night address followed a
passionate speech from Ukraine's
president zielinski video linked from
Keith
Russia once wore its true but Russia
will not be able to stop the cause of
History
Mankind and their international law are
stronger than one terrorist State though
he couldn't see it the reaction was the
one he'd wanted
as for President Putin's Stark nuclear
threats well this wasn't the moment for
off the cuff responses prime minister
what'd you make of uh Vladimir Putin's
comments this morning
is it time for NATO to double down for
the EU to Double Down
there was anticipation instead for how
America's President Biden would react to
the language from Moscow well here he is
arriving just now a little later than
planned and with a speech that has been
altered as a consequence of what Mr
Putin has been saying
and from the podium he was blunt and he
was firm
we do not seek conflict
we do not seek a cold war
a nuclear war
cannot be won
and must never be fought then from the
chamber to the first one-on-one meeting
with prime minister trust we are
supporting the ukrainians in their fight
for freedom but we Face huge challenges
Ukraine the focus of course and
naturally a united front but the body
language was stiff two nations with a
special relationship yes but two leaders
with very different politics and no
obvious rapport
the next Focus here later today a
security council meeting of foreign
ministers watch for a clash of words
Russia's Sergey lavrov opposite
America's Tony blinken and Britain's new
foreign secretary James cleverley Mark
Stone Sky News in New York
meanwhile five British prisoners of War
who were being held by pro-russian
forces have been released as part of a
prisoner swap deal brokered by the Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia three of them
have been identified as Aiden Aslan John
Harding and Sean Penner who were all
captured by russian-backed separatists
in eastern Ukraine last April in a
personal message recorded on their
flight home Mr Aslan and Mr Pinner thank
those who had supported them over the
last few months
we just want to let everyone know that
we're now out of the danger zone and
we're on our way home to our families
we just want everyone to know the good
news Etc so thanks to everyone that's
been supportive
it's really emotionally appreciated
[Music]
I think it's fair to say exhausted but
relieved our security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes is with us in kharkiv in
northeastern Ukraine um hi Deborah one
wonders why now as far as these men are
concerned
well it does seem that this is the
result of a long period of negotiative
negotiation between the two sides Saudi
Arabia and turkey playing a key role as
well in mediating in total there's more
than 280 detainees that have been
exchanged the majority of them
ukrainians
215 ukrainians in total and the majority
of those are the ones that held out in
the as of style steel plant in Mario
Paul you'll remember that's that Port
City in the south of the country that
was obliterated by Russian weaponry and
that one steel plant held out preventing
President Putin from being able to
declare Victory there for a long period
of time and there's been huge worry
about what was going to happen to those
people and clearly a big priority for
Ukraine to get them back and in exchange
they have released
um Victor medvichuk who is a Ukrainian
here he was the head head of a banned
pro-russian party he had been arrested
and was facing potential treason charges
he's gone to Russia now along with 55
Russians and pro-rush pro-russian
ukrainians who had been in captivity and
as well of course as you've mentioned
there's the the five British Nationals
that have been released as well as five
other foreign Nationals who'd come here
to fight for the ukrainians but had been
detained by Russia and one final point
to make yes it's significant that this
has happened now it's interesting that
it's happened at this moment given the
escalation in the language and the
strategy from the Russian side but it's
also a sign that the two sides have been
able to speak to reach a compromise and
exchange individuals that they both deem
to be valuable showing that there is an
ability to communicate still
okay thank you Deborah thank you
at home all patients in England should
be offered an appointment to see their
GP within a fortnight as part of new
government plans to help tackle
pressures in the NHS but doctors have
already hit out at the proposals saying
new targets will have a minimal impact
on patient care this morning we'll bring
you a sense of the challenges facing the
NHS from workers on the front line
joining us now is NHS nurse Carmel
O'Boyle who works at a walk-in Center in
Liverpool hello to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
what sort of challenges are you seeing
at the moment
morning we're seeing a record number of
patients trying to come through the door
and trying to access Healthcare and
we're having difficulties with that
because there aren't enough of us
um the government wants to prioritize
emergencies
um backlog and
care I mean that that is a good thing
isn't it how do you go about doing that
though
of course it's a good thing but there's
not enough of us so the government keeps
you know bringing out these plans this
Army of volunteers that they're bringing
from from goodness knows where and I
don't really understand how or where
these people are coming from we need
more nurses more Health Care staff and
the the only way to tackle this crisis
is to get more of us
okay so has the not the numbers have
dropped I know there's something like
100
000 vacancies out there in the NHS at
the moment why do you think the figures
have dropped is it because of burnout is
it because uh of brexit and um people
from outside the UK not being able to
come into work here
I think I think it's a multitude of Kind
of Perfect Storm if you like but the the
pay is is an enormous thing we can't
recruit and retain people into the the
NHS or the healthcare system because the
pay is not fair and and that's one of
the things we're asking for at the
moment and is is fair pay and for us to
be able to to attract more people into
the profession so we need more students
we need a better funded education system
and we need we need a better place to
work
where more work is going to come from
though in in your opinion comma
I I wish I knew this this Army of
volunteered at the keep you know
dragging out from goodness knows where
are we are we taking people away from
their well-earned retirement and
dragging them back into work that I
don't know it seems a panicked and
vertical thing to ask to be honest that
um we're gonna bring these these people
from from nowhere at this volunteer army
to help you know with the NHS Workforce
crisis we need more people trained we
need more students
and we are recruiting from overseas but
again as you've said brexit has brought
difficulties with that
talk to me um let's explore a little bit
more about when you were talking about
pay I think that a lot of the NHS unions
are pushing for above inflation pay
Rises I mean I'm not sure that that's
going to happen are you
and well he is hoping but after years
and years of austerity you know anything
that that doesn't match inflation is a
pay quote for people this winter is a
terrifying time for finesses that we
have nurses in our area who are really
frightened about how they're going to
Coop this winter with a you know cost of
living crisis with extra fuel bills and
and all of those things people don't
know how they're going to cope people
are having to use food banks to feed
their children it's it's unprecedented
and it's important
and when you speak to your colleagues
are you getting the impression that
enough is enough they've had to deal
with covid and the pandemic and they're
having to deal with not as many staff
around
um they're burnt out because they can't
cope they don't feel like they're
getting enough money and are there are
your colleagues than you at a stage now
where you're thinking you know what
we're just going to have to withdraw our
labor unless we get more money
I I think that's where we are at as you
say enough is enough there's only so
much people can cope with and and after
the past you know two years of working
at this level you can't do any more
you're asking people to pour from
anti-cups that you cannot do anymore it
needs to be fair remuneration for what
they have gone through and and so that
you can kind of sit in a comfortable
position knowing that whatever work
you're going to do at least pay your
bills and nobody wants to to go out on
strike or take industrial election but
this is the this is where we are this is
what we're faced with the government
needs to listen and if this is the way
that we have to attract their attention
then Sylvia
and how serious is that threat do you
think um and when might that happen
it's really serious and I think um we've
kind of said before you know well I
don't want to strike and and I don't
want to put patients at risk but the
fact of the matter is because there's
not enough of us patients are at risk
and all any nurse any healthcare worker
wants to do is to safely look after the
patients we need safe staff and we need
more of us and the only way to make the
government listen now it is for us to
take some kind of drastic action I I
think this is coming
um what would you say to Therese coffee
the health secretary and Deputy Prime
Minister this morning
come and speak to healthcare workers you
want a healthcare plan come and speak to
people who are working in it because I
I'm not sure where the government get
their ideas from but it's certainly not
from from people who are in the midst of
this this kind of rhetoric that you know
we'll we will get people through to see
the GPS more quickly we're ready again
these GPS from no GP sat on the Laurels
throughout the pandemic thinking we have
a lovely easy time here people are
desperate to get their patients seen and
to care for patients so that that's all
that we want to do you need to listen to
us
okay it's good to talk to you um Carmel
I hope that you get what you are hoping
for and thank you so much for your
service we really do appreciate it thank
you thank you
see what the front pages are saying this
morning should be starting with the
financial times leading with the latest
from Russia the headline Putin makes
nuclear threat as he mobilizes Army
Reserves for war
the Metro goes with reactions from the
Russian public to Putin's threats the
headline Russians see red at Vlad
the mail shares prime minister trust his
response to Putin we won't be coward by
nuclear threats swans the UK leader
the times also leads with Biden's
remarks as he Brands Putin's comments as
Reckless
the sun tells of the five British
captives released in Ukraine amid the
escalating tensions there
was actually promising all patients must
get a doctor's appointment within two
weeks is on the front of the express
and the mirror leaves with the ongoing
search for Olivia Pratt corbell's killer
with a record reward of 200 000 pounds
being offered to help find the gunman
still to come on the program for you
this Thursday morning with the energy
price is soaring we'll speak to the chef
Tom Carriage to find out if the support
offered by the government will be enough
then we'll be looking ahead to Friday's
so-called mini budget joined by the
leader of the liberal Democrats that's
the Ed Davy
and in the next hour joined in the
studio by Labor's Shadow Health
secretary that's West Street in
before that though News about Donald
Trump and three of his children they've
been served with a civil lawsuit
alleging years of Bank tax and insurance
fraud by the New York attorney general
Leticia James the Trump organization
denies misrepresenting property
valuations to secure favorable loans and
tax benefits iOS correspondent Martha
Kellner has the latest
this is a major development in this
ongoing civil investigation led by
Leticia James who's the Attorney General
of New York and she's announcing that
she on behalf of New York state is suing
Donald Trump and his three eldest
children Don Jr Eric and Ivanka she's
seeking 250 million dollars and also to
ban any of those four individuals from
running a company in New York state ever
again so this would clearly have huge
implications for how the Trump
organization is run in the future given
that that is an organization
headquartered in New York state she says
she alleges in this lawsuit that over
more than a decade they inflated the
value of their assets mainly property in
order to defraud lenders and mislead the
tax authorities now Trump and the Trump
organization as you would expect have
moved quickly to rebuff this lawsuit
they say that Leticia James is is a
Democrat trying to advance her political
agenda and they say that these claims
are meritless but just another of the
ongoing legal problems both criminal uh
and civil that Donald Trump is fighting
at the moment
remember of course that the midterms in
the United States elections are in
November the month after next now is the
cost of living continues to bite there
could be another blow to mortgage
holders and knock on for renters with
the bank of England expected to raise
interest rates again today it's possible
we could see the largest single increase
in more than 30 years in a bid to try to
keep inflation under control markets
suggest the bank could raise the base
rate from 1.75 to 2.5 percent let's
bring in Maddie should we who's standing
by for us in North London that's a
three-quarters of a percentage points
Maddie what's that going to mean for the
housing market
well any interest rate rise especially
one that big is going to be felt most
immediately in mortgages anyone who has
a mortgage that isn't fixed so it's
variable and follows that bank of
England base rate will see their
mortgage go up anyone looking to
remortgage or anyone looking for a new
mortgage if they're buying their
mortgages will become more expensive but
it's not just homeowners as well if
you're a renter and your landlord has a
mortgage and that mortgage goes up
they're likely to pass those costs on so
it affects rental affordability as well
and really since 2008 if the bank raises
rates as it's expected to to 2.5 percent
the highest it's been since then and the
financial crisis a whole generation of
people have grown up with those very low
interest rates very low mortgage costs
and this will be a real shock and it
will certainly make the cost of buying
the cost of moving off the rental market
more expensive and more remote for many
it's a sad irony that the move designed
to bring down inflation if you raise
rates that tends to bring down inflation
will actually make the day-to-day cost
of living so much more expensive for
many people indeed so thanks very much
indeed we'll hear from the bank of
England later on today meantime looking
at some of today's other headlines for
you know and the Metropolitan Police has
been told to make urgent improvements
after a watchdog raised serious concerns
about its performance report a report
published by his Majesty's inspectorate
of constabulary and Fire and Rescue
Services said Scotland Yard was failing
in several areas Britain's biggest
police force was graded inadequate in
the way it responds to the public
in Iran at least eight people have now
been killed in continuing protests
following the death of a woman who was
detained by the country's morality
police rasa amini died in custody last
week after she was accused of breaking
the law requiring women to cover their
head with a hijab
NHS leaders are calling for extra social
care funding to help alleviate what
they're predicting will be the most
extreme winter pressures the service has
ever faced the NHS Confederation says
that social care investment will be the
best and most effective action the
government could take
doctors have held a milestone treatment
for motor neurone disease or mnd around
5000 people in the UK have the disease
which gradually takes away their ability
to walk Talk use their arms and hands
eat and breathe for patients who were
given monthly injections of the new drug
topherson reported better mobility and
lung function after a year of treatment
let's take you to Huddersfield where a
murder investigation is underway after a
15 year old boy was stabbed to death
outside a school Fraser standing by for
us in Huddersfield this morning what on
Earth happened here Fraser good morning
morning Cape yeah tragic events here on
the main road outside the north
Huddersfield trust school which unfolded
around five to three yesterday afternoon
it was just after lessons had ended the
majority of the school two children were
leaving the school this wood is an area
that would have been very very busy at
that time yesterday afternoon and police
say that they do have a number of
witnesses already identified who are
they are talking to who they're
Gathering evidence from in terms of what
happened here what we know so far is
that a 15 year old boy on leaving school
was attacked stabbed in the street he
was taken to Leeds General infirmary
where attempts to save him sadly failed
and he was pronounced dead a short time
after he arrived there here at the scene
only two small areas at the moment
cordoned off by police one just here
behind me where there's a bag of what
appears to be medical waste the remnants
Grim remnants of the of the attempts by
the Emergency Services one would imagine
to save this young boy's life and
another small area just about 50 meters
or so up on the other side of the road
there that's been sealed off by police
these are clearly two key areas which
forensic officers will be examining
later on today police say that there
will be further forensic examinations
here at the scene as their investigation
continues and of course an awful lot of
people to talk to in terms of potential
Witnesses potentially dozens of
witnesses many of them young school
children many of them parents one would
imagine for the police to talk to so a
lot of work to be done there they'll
also be looking for any mobile phone
footage any CCTV footage to help them
with their inquiry it's been dealt with
by the West uh West Yorkshire police's
homicide and major inquiry team and
their senior officer detective
superintendent Mark Bowes said our
investigation is still at a very early
stage and we will be carrying out
extensive inquiries to establish the
full circumstances surrounding this
incident that has resulted in the
absolutely senseless loss of a young
life they say that they recognize that
incidents of this nature will cause
shock concerned not only amongst the 900
school children who attend the north
Huddersfield trust school but of course
of their parents and people in the local
area so they're saying that they're
going to step up patrols here kirkley's
Council are also putting people on the
ground here to reassure parents to raise
short reassure children that they are
safe as this murder investigation here
in Huddersfield continues following the
death of a 15 year old boy okay uh
prasadena thanks so much indeed just
finished lessons for the day pinned down
and stabbed to death outside of his
school my goodness me uh let's get Mona
on the government's new plans to improve
access to NHS and social care uh joining
us now uh Saba who has more details for
us hi um Sabbath so what are the plans
good morning Kate well the ambition
essentially is to give people greater
access to the National Health Services
we approach this winter and the next now
Therese Kofi is expected to make a
statement later where she will map out
how as health secretary she hopes to do
this now the big thing that we can
expect her to talk about is GP
appointments now she is saying that
individuals or patients should not have
to wait for more than two weeks to see
their local GP and one of the ways that
she is going about to do this we
understand is by giving individuals like
pharmacists more Powers essentially so
the ability to prescribe certain
contraceptions which they currently are
unable to do and by doing this we
understand that around 2 million or more
people will be able to be seen by GPS
and also giving pharmacists the
opportunity to see people for things
like headaches sore throats and also
colds now in theory this sounds great
but gp's leading GPS are not happy and
are saying it's going to increase the
workloads for them we'll have an overall
minimal impact and will create a league
table essentially in terms of the
different GPS in the country but for
greater details we'll have to wait for
her statement later we will about half
past 10 in the House of Commons thanks
very much indeed uh joining us now
Deputy chair of the general
practitioners Committee in England
that's Dr David Wrigley um hello to you
Doctor thank you so much for joining us
on the program this morning as we were
saying we'll have to wait for the detail
from the health secretary and Deputy
Prime Minister what do you want to see
yes thank you um we're pleased to see
announcements made but the what we see
in this package really doesn't go far
enough we as GPS as doctors you know we
want to see patients get access to us we
I see the scramble you know on the
phones to try and get appointments and
it it's something that really does
affect us we want patients to be seen in
a timely fashion we'll see patients
urgently that day but we know that for
the routine appointments the weight can
be sometimes two weeks or more we we
have solutions for this you know we want
to sit down and talk to the Secretary of
State but these announcements have been
made without any discussion myself and
three other colleagues represent 30 000
GPS across England we've had no
communication no chance to sit down with
the secretary of state and outline the
issues and how we can solve this problem
so that you so just to be clear the um
the health secretary is coming up with
her new plan today uh telling us all
about it at the dispatch box and hasn't
spoken to the relevant Frontline workers
she hasn't spoken to the representatives
of the profession so we we work you know
to represent doctors across England uh
looking after 60 million patients day in
day out uh 1.2 million appointments a
day in general practice and we haven't
had the opportunity to talk about the
problems how we can get the solutions uh
to sort the problem out and you know the
package we see today uh some of it is is
going to help a little bit but it's
going to go nowhere near sorting the
major problem we have with doctors
unable to cope you know burnt out
working 13-hour days a huge backlog that
we've seen through covid and even before
kovid we had a major backlog on problems
with waiting lists and it it's just been
compounded and it really has created a
massive problem for our patients so we
want to just try and help as much as we
can
I I do remember speaking to previous
um Health secretaries telling me about
the 6 000 more GPS that we will see in
the system by 2024.
um how are we as far as that's concerned
that's what 18 months a couple of years
away
well it's a woeful figure we've probably
lost her lost around 2 000 full-time
equivalent GPS in the last five years or
so and you know these are the promises
we had from the politicians of 6 000
more GPS and we need more nurses and
admin staff we need a huge cut in the
red tape and bureaucracy we spend hours
every week chasing targets and filling
out forms and pharmacists in my practice
probably spend a day a week and chasing
these targets and they could be seeing
patients that's you know that will help
massively
um and I hope the Secretary of State
listens and and you know we can help
solve some of these problems if she'll
sit down and talk with us
pure doctors means more patients per GP
obviously simple maths at what stage
will that start to impact on the care
that can be offered to patients
well it already is impacting you know we
know the population is increasing we see
new housing Estates going up there's
never any discussion around another GP
surgery or how do we get GPS to look
after these patients probably in the
last five years the average doctor's
seen an extra 300 patients on their list
and that's that's additional
appointments that are needed but no
discussion around how we deal with that
how do we get more doctors and nurses
into general practice to look after
these patients we've got premises that
are often woefully inadequate we don't
have the space to put doctors in nurses
into and again we've asked for a support
around premises for GPS and it it just
falls on deaf ears and we we really need
that conversation with the politicians
an in-depth conversation about the
solutions that we have for them what
would you say to them about how you
retain the workforce
well it's not going to happen overnight
you know we've got a demoralized
Workforce that often you know GPS were
lambasted last year and ongoing about
not seeing patients face-to-face we
haven't closed for one day during the
pandemic we continue to see patients we
we didn't see them face to face because
we had a deadly virus that was around
and you don't want a packed waiting room
but if we need to see patients face to
face we'll do it yet we saw an
orchestrated media attack on GPS not
seeing patients and uh no not doing the
work they should do and that was backed
up by the government the previous
secretaries like we've had three now in
six months actually the previous
Secretary of State backed up the media
and that just doesn't help with them
trying to solve the problems before and
so you know we've got a Workforce on its
knees uh trying to deal with the
patients day-to-day and we need we need
Solutions around cutting red tape
improving premises we've got a massive
problem with pension taxation for senior
doctors the treasury again won't listen
they don't want to talk to us about the
solutions we've got there's Lots we
could do we just want the chance to talk
down put them in place and then we might
start to solve the problems we have
before us
um you've had something like three
Health secretaries in um just over a
couple of months in fact
um do you feel that the government is
taking the Health Service Center
in England no I don't feel that that's
the case you know we've got a package of
measures today that really aren't going
to solve the problem we we're here
there's going to be digital phone lines
to help patients get through who's going
to answer the phones you know we don't
have the staff we don't have the support
there to help us deal with these
problems so you know these headlines
might sound okay and you know from the
dispatch box it looks like things are
being dealt with but you know it's not
going to solve the problems that we have
you know major problems that we want to
do our best for patients yeah we all we
became doctors to help patients and
support them when you when you can't do
that and you don't feel you can work
safely and you're absolutely on your
knees at eight o'clock in the evening
after a 13-hour day that is not the way
he's for patients to be looked after and
we really need to start looking
seriously at how we tackle these
problems rather than just headline
grabbing announcements that really all
make a difference
okay doctor thank you very much today
for joining us thank you
don't forget the announcement from the
health secretary will be in the House of
Commons right about half past 10 or
thereabouts from the dispatch box this
morning uh meantime check this out
there's new scientific evidence that
children's dislike of greens could start
in the womb
[Music]
see this little chap apparently
researchers at Durham University took
scans of 100 pregnant women after they
ate either carrots or kale if they had
kale fetuses went from a neutral face to
a frown but they were exposed to carrots
instead they went from neutral to
Smiling as you can see in this bottom
photo here he obviously likes carrots
when um I was pregnant I used to eat
sushi all the time I was told not to but
that's what the baby wanted and he still
eats it devours it today
he's 30. now time for a look through
some of the photos that have caught our
eye for you this morning here we go why
did the pig cross the road the answer it
turns out is to Hoover up acorns
hundreds of pigs have been released into
the New Forest hotels in Hampshire as
part of the annual passage a tradition
dating back centuries in which the pigs
clear up acorns and nuts which can be
poisonous to ponies and cattle
um
is it though hogwash I didn't write that
I'm going to move on oh thank you Tim on
your bike this former petrol station has
been transformed into a hub for cyclists
to Mark World Car free day it aims to
show how Urban spaces can be reimagined
to help support a reduction in carbon
emissions there we are
and check this out for an autumn sunrise
the spectacular shot of a flock of birds
in flight was taken over Dungeness in
Kent isn't that beautiful sunrise
goodness me what a lovely Island we live
on uh still to come on the program next
part of the program Energy prices
spiraling we'll speak to Chef Tom
Carriage to find out if the support
offered by the government will be
anywhere near enough for businesses like
his that to come
Hello everybody welcome back to the
morning show here on Sky News Thursday
morning the new prime minister addressed
the UN General Assembly for the first
time as leader overnight and while her
Focus was the war in Ukraine Lewis trust
also set out her vision for the country
and the economy let's have a listen
I will lead a New Britain for a new era
firstly this begins with growth and
building a British economy that rewards
Enterprise and attracts investment
our long-term aim is to get our economy
growing it's an average of 2.5 percent
we need this growth to deliver
investment around our country to deliver
the jobs and high wages people expect
and deliver Public Services like the
National Health Service
yeah National Health Service very much
on people's minds this morning are they
interesting that one of the doctors were
saying to us so we were chatting to him
our third Health secretary in three
months how seriously is this government
taking the NHS well this was something
that Liz truss said on the steps of
Downing Street wasn't it she said that
she has three priorities one of them she
made very clear was fixing the NHS and
we know I mean we've all seen those
extraordinary images of ambulances
queuing outside hospitals we all know
that they're extraordinary any waiting
times fixing that is not going to be
easy there's also a enormous problem
with Staffing in the anhs 130 000
vacancies and they're training less
doctors Therese coffee this morning we
expect in the next couple of hours going
to be standing up with a plan part of
that is about getting people to see GPS
faster she says she wants people to see
them within two weeks that's not
actually an official Target though so
whether or not in practice how that's
going to work remains to be seen and
there are some including the NHS
Confederation that Warner actually what
she's saying isn't necessarily going to
tackle the scale of this it's all going
to take money we've got a mini budget or
is it a fiscal event I can't remember
what we're calling good question I think
we're calling it the government suddenly
want to call it a fiscal event it's not
a full-scale budget we're not going to
get to widespread announcements on
things like tobacco and fuel Duty what
we will get though is extraordinary
spending commitments we know that the
government want to freeze energy bills
and we know that we were speaking yes
about how they want to give businesses
the estimates are that this is going to
cost more than 150 billion pounds so
extraordinary amounts of money that the
government is spending there will not be
an obr the Watchdog forecast alongside
that that has brought some criticism the
obr did say they could do it in time
that this is a government so just to
clear the obr is the office for Budget
responsibility and they look at the
figures and say whether they're going to
work or not exactly so they usually do a
forecast alongside a proper budget and
they would scrutinize that so some are
saying this is a government that don't
want to be scrutinized but Liz truss on
her way home from New York today as you
say quasi-cotting will be making that
statement tomorrow and of course we have
the backdrop of rising interest rates
warnings that they could be as high as
three and a half percent by the end of
the year many people are paying double
so it's it's a pretty bleak economic
backdrop that's not going to be driving
people spending but this is a government
that say that they are all about pushing
for growth it is a Gamble and let's
trust has said that she is willing to be
unpopular about three quarters of a
percent likely um we'll find out later
on today yeah exactly that's what we're
expecting today okay
um Ali for now thanks so much indeed uh
well yesterday was just hearing there
from Ali the government announced it
would slash wholesale energy costs for
businesses by up to a half their
expected price through the winter months
but has the intervention come too late
for businesses already on the brink as a
result of spiraling bills let's bring in
a chef and restaurant owner Tom Kerry
Rich who has already seen prices
increase he says by 700 percent at some
of his businesses joins us now hi Tom's
good to see you um talk me through um
your the challenges that you're facing
with your energy bills at the moment
morning Kate yeah I I mean the rising
cost I mean we're all hearing about it
and it the problem with uh business is
that at the minute there was no cap and
now there is a cap coming in but we need
to know what that cap is where it sits
many people have got their business uh
energy contract signed up
um but are beginning to drop out of it
between now October and through to
December and uh our first quote for one
of our particular spaces has gone from
um 14 Pence per kilowatt hour up to one
pound and two pence per kilowatt hour so
and this is a place that uses uh 35
between 32 and 35
000 kilowatts per hour per month so it's
rising from around about 60 000 pounds a
year up to 420
000 pounds a year now obviously we
haven't signed that contract we are
shopping around and looking but it's
such a volatile Market at the minute
that nobody knows where those prices are
sitting and where they're going to be
and if that business price cap does come
in and say it's even only half that but
that still is a an increase of you know
300 many many businesses are going to
struggle with paying that I mean listen
I recognize it myself on a personal
basis I'm in a very different position
but as an industry it's going to
struggle it's going to be very very
difficult to deal with if you think of
those amazing lovely local pubs that you
know the the gorgeous little uh uh um
City Center bars and restaurants and
spaces where where the landlord perhaps
lives upstairs and and may be able is
able to EK to salary uh of you know 25
30 000 pounds a year but um because they
live upstairs but if their energy
increases to another 25 30 40 50 100 000
pound a year then these businesses just
become absolutely non-viable and and
it's it's a real shame because that's
the reality for many places in
Hospitality that those margarines sit on
those few percentage points
yeah and it's I'm guessing it's not just
uh pubs and restaurants like yours it's
the suppliers and it's all the other
companies that you're working with as
well yeah that's exactly that you look
at Food inflation in the way that that's
hitting the industry and then uh you
know those business costs those Energy
prices are going into butchers they're
going into Farmers they're going into
fish mongers and all those sort of
suppliers and then what happens from
there is that that is obviously a
parallel cost that comes into the
business
um and what happens then is it's
inevitable that those costs are going to
have to go up
um the prices then go up on the menu but
at the same point everybody at home is
sitting there with a uh with less money
in their pocket so what happens is that
you know hospitality is one point but
it's the same for everybody it's the
same for retail and Manufacturing that
the end cost of an ingredient sits at
one point and the money in people's
pocket is another and it feels like it's
pulling two polars apart
so what does the government need to do
to help businesses like yours going
forward
so I mean obviously the business price
cap coming in is something that's um
obviously going to be of a great help to
many many businesses we just need to
know a little bit more of the detail in
that um but there's another there's a
number of things that the government
could do I think um a review and a look
at the business rates and the way that
they're calculated Hospitality gets
punished quite heavily on business rates
you know it's it's calculated on the
rateable value of the business and that
business appears to be a heavier in a
Hospitality space and it does perhaps
the majority of the High Street but also
Frontline tax breaks in terms of vat a
decrease would be incredibly helpful for
many businesses up front and reducing
the amount that you pay incorporating
tax is fantastic that is great but that
only works if there's a business that's
making profit so any help that the
government needs to do for for
Hospitality for manufacturing should
come in as a Frontline reduction in vat
that will allow your business to operate
um particularly whether that's
short-term whether it's a six month 12
month or 18 month opportunity to get
through these difficult
um winter period
um while we've got you I wondered if you
had any sort of tips that you could
share with people at home for keeping
bills and and costs down um as a chef
I'm thinking obviously we spend a lot of
money on our energy bills in the kitchen
don't we yeah absolutely you know we we
do it you spend a lot of time cooking I
mean one of the big things one of the
big things I would say is menu planning
or organize what you're going to do
um and how you're going to cook it
during the week like it it doesn't it's
not necessarily the most creative every
evening that you go and go what am I
going to cook this evening but if you've
got that structure you keep your costs
down on your food costs you know you buy
just exactly what you need and have a
look at batch cooking so if you're going
to cook a a large portion of bolognese
sauce for example you know do it for two
weeks worth and and freeze it so the
next time all you've got to do is reheat
it rather than cook it with an extra
hour and a half but little tricks and
tips like that they all go a long long
way cooking things in one pan
um and just the opportunity of trying to
do things that are a little bit quicker
as well
okay just before I let you go what's
your message to quasi quattang where
there's mini budget tomorrow
yeah I mean I hope that you've been
listening to many members of the
industry that have been
um sending uh emails and and letters and
direct conversation
um regarding a reduction in vat and uh
very much a review of business rates so
uh you know we're very hopeful but it's
it's a critical couple of days
um for for the hospitality industry and
many others around
it's good to talk to you um uh always
great to see you thanks very much thanks
Tom thanks
Britain has become more woke and over
half of the population half of the
population are in favor of higher taxes
those are two of a number of findings
from this year's British social attitude
survey from the national Center for
social research let's have a look should
we the survey found the majority of
Britain want the government to increase
taxes and also spending that's not what
we're expecting tomorrow for the first
time more people want the voting system
to change with a clear majority among
labor supporters the survey also
suggested that Britain is more
politically polarized than ever before
on whether Scotland should become an
independent country also found woke
attitudes are increasingly common in
Britain though so-called culture War
issues continue to divide the nation
interesting stuff let's get more though
on Friday's so-called mini budget in
which the government will outline their
multi-billion pound plan for the economy
so Ed Davey's here with me good morning
great to see you thanks for joining us
um so people want more higher taxes
um well I think not sure if everybody
does um what I'm really worried about is
the government are going to cut taxes
for large corporations and things like
bankers and banks will get the Lion's
Share of that they're refusing to put
taxes up which I do support on oil and
gas companies oil and gas companies
making huge profits tens of billions of
pounds and liberal Democrats believe
there should be a windfall tax on those
taxes should go up on those oil and gas
companies and use that money to fund the
support for struggling families and for
small businesses the moment the
government's help for for people is
coming out of borrowing and that's quite
dangerous and risky uh there's a danger
that will put up interest rates even
more and so struggling families will be
hit by high energy prices higher food
prices and higher mortgage rates that is
a real worry for people higher energy
prices I thought they were going to be
capped well I wish they were little
Democrats called for a energy price uh
cap to be frozen early summer the
governments are doing something but
they're actually allowing NG bills to go
up by another 500 pounds in October so
they went up by 700 pounds in April
they're going up by another 500 pounds
that's not a freeze that's an increase
and maybe 500 pounds isn't a lot for
conservative MPS but for their
constituents it's a huge amount of money
but they are then going to freeze bills
aren't they for two years which handily
Falls almost to when the next election
might be some might say they were
particularly being skeptical but you
know they are doing something and it's
going to cost a lot of money well
they're not doing enough for struggling
families because then allowing energy
bills to go up by another 500 pounds and
one of the reasons they're not able to
do enough because they're not taking the
decision to tax the oil and gas
companies on their tens of billions of
pounds of unexpected profit so I think
the government don't have a good plan
they're economic plan seems non-existent
it seems to be wrong about the economy
that's what they're trying to do that's
what's been explained to us well there's
no plan for that is a lot of ideology a
lot of rhetoric but not a serious plan
to help stronger families and businesses
you were talking to the gentleman from
the hospitality sector the government
have failed the hospital Hospitality
sector and their current plan uh to help
businesses on energy bills doesn't go
far enough it's only for six months you
know businesses will be reviewed after
six months not just six months they're
going to look at it again but if you're
a business employing people wanting to
investment you need a degree of
certainty and stability and the
government aren't providing that one of
the key things you need in in a real
economic plan which liberal Democrats
are putting forward is a long-term
approach and frankly something that can
last for a few months is not sufficient
for businesses who are trying to employ
people
um it looks as though According to some
the recession has been fended off so I
mean we have to give this trust credit
for that don't we I don't think this
trust gets any credit for it and or the
conservative party they have mismanaged
our economy
um they are actually threatening the
future by having such a high level of of
borrowing to fund tax cuts for large
companies and for and for the the banks
that means they're threatening the
stability of our economy and interest
rates will go up far higher as a result
of that Reckless approach on borrowing
she has said I mean I'm just looking at
quotes from this trust you just say that
she's admitted that her text plans would
to start with disproportionately help
richer people and that's what she was
saying but she's doing that in order to
get the economy to grow surely that's a
good thing well um if it were true it
would be good but it's not true
um she's putting forward a very
ideological right-wing approach which
says that if you give lots of money to
the wealthiest it will trickle down to
everyone else that type of trickle-down
economics has been tried before and it's
failed Britain is a very honest Reagan
wouldn't agree with you on that I think
well I'm afraid America is a very
unequal society and Britain is a very
unequal society and it's partly because
conservatives have put forward this
proposal before and it's failed liberal
Democrats are saying we want a fairer
country and fairer taxes okay that's why
we've argued for this windfall tax on
the energy what else apart from that
because that's not enough well we
wouldn't proceed with this big
Corporation tax cut they're talking
about most of that money or a large slug
of that money goes to Banks and to to
multinational companies it doesn't
actually help many small businesses 1.4
million small businesses won't get any
help at all from that corporation tax
cut yet they're the ones who are
struggling the most and the Democrats
are saying you've got to look after
those small businesses those they're
small and medium-sized Enterprise
Enterprises who are really the growth
engine for our economy if you want the
economy to grow to grow local Democrats
would first of all back that small
business sector secondly we have a
serious plan on Energy prices and that
would include helping our industry to be
more efficient with energy because that
makes a more competitive internationally
we'd also insulate people's homes and
move faster to Renewables because that's
the cheapest form of energy that's a
real plan for cutting prices for making
our economy more competitive and
preparing ourselves for the future the
government they don't really have a plan
it's it's ideology and it's been tried
before and it's failed yeah but
insulating people's homes is costing is
going to cost quite a lot of money how
do we pay for that well it would save
money in the long term but you have to
pay for it to start with well you do but
there's that sort of investment to say
that investment to make ourselves more
competitive is sensible our criticism
the government approach is they're
borrowing to fund tax cuts for the
better off and for Bankers that's not
sustainable our approach to the
Louisville Democrat approach is
sustainable it's sustainable in terms of
our environment but in sustainable in
terms of finances and I am genuinely
worried for our country K you know I
hope that by getting rid of Boris
Johnson and having a new start the
conservatives would bring the country
together would start having a sensible
economic plan for our country I'm afraid
uh the reverse has happened I think this
looks even worse
um you had to or you chose to cancel
your party conference uh how difficult a
decision was that and she was quite easy
once we learned that uh that our late
Manchester's funeral was going to be on
the Monday of our conference we clearly
weren't going to go ahead uh in that in
that position and you know like the rest
of the country we are still really
feeling that sadness at the loss of of
our lay Queen and we didn't think that
Party politics uh just in that run up to
the funeral and the funeral itself was
the right thing to do so we decided we
would cancel our conference Mr cost you
a fortune
I think in the context of where our
country was we need to be come together
and liberal Democrats wanted to show we
were doing a little bit along with
millions of other people to bring our
country together to say goodbye to our
Queen and to to get behind our new king
and um yes it I'm not suggesting it
didn't cost anything it did but you know
sometimes things are more important than
that understood than money
um talk to me about the by-election
quickly Before I Let You Go Rosie Cooper
Labor's Rosie Cooper stepping down in
West Lancashire there will be a
by-election
um it's not a lib Dem stick really is it
I mean you've got 4.9 of the vote back
in 2019 are you going to step aside so
labor has a free run well first of all
can I pay two Rosie Cooper I think he's
just he's been a great MP um and uh I
think she'll be missed by all sides of
the house and um well I'm sure she's
going on to other things and do do lots
of other contributions I think we should
acknowledge uh her contribution so far I
mean we look at every uh seat when it
comes up we're not going by election no
of course not and we look at everything
uh seriously but what we don't do is is
waste money we don't go into elections
where we're not convinced we can can win
and spend huge amounts of our resources
there we tend to Target our resources I
think that's a rational thing but you
may step aside
um no we won't step aside we fight we
give the lecters always a choice you
will definitely of course we're the
candidate of course we'll have a
candidate I think that's the Democratic
thing to do I believe in giving people
uh Choice what I would say is that you
know we have shown that by-elections
over the last year that we can we we can
win and people didn't expect us to we
beat the conservatives in three uh seats
last time in the last last 12 months in
Tory Heartland in True Blue Book I'm
sure in North Shropshire where they held
it for 200 years absolutely they're in
East Devon so little Democrats are doing
well in these by-elections when when
people hear our case they come behind us
we're out of time it's always great to
see you thank you sir Ed for joining us
on the program this morning